Arwa. But that's how the pedals. This is the. I do get a young child now so i do hu washing every few days.
Nappies and stuff. As you can see it going to throw but washing machine here and a yeah. It has been dry.
And i you know i've experimented with them. With paper washing machines but those knew of it.
Terribly happy with him because. You couldn't walk away from it. You know you were totally involved in the wash.
And you had to be there for the entire education of the boy. With a twelve washing machine i could just turn it on.
Walk away. When the washing finished i just come back.
Take the washing out the washing machine throw it into the paper spin dry that there has been dry is great because i
just get up to speed takes about fifteen seconds is paid lip to speed. And you just it's been you know. It's.
The pedal spin dry is actually quite a bit they the saving devices set you mean it's still doing itself this of all the
easier than having to ring in the last you know that really well. And you get this legs in the business.
Yeah well i've not pedaling as much as i used to having a thing.
I find that i can do all the shopping on the bicycle so i tend to make use of it. Now i've got a cat that runs on gas.
It's not this polluting as with most vehicles that. I am relying on on the. To do shopping and stuff.
It's not getting as much use to do. What other things if you ask. Here i'll show you some of the stuff later.
As you can see this is a pedal spin dryer and on the other side. A multi purpose better machine a high speed.
Machine it's basically just a very clean man to check. Through a bench top and.
That's been dry here by the way it's been thirty five to one. So every time the pedals go round once.
This been dry goes around thirty five times. The that. The pedal. The multi-speed. That's going to seventy two and.
For every time that there was going around one seat. Jack at the top spin seventy times.
That means that pedaling at the rate of a comfortable pedaling rate is probably hundred hundred twenty. At the end.
That made it that things doing. That eighty eight thousand. Pretty good output. It works really well. Ok. Yes.
This is the all the speed. Story. The multipurpose high speed pedal machinist don't you have enough.
You can see he's got one.
Going to really force it to china's own
and so forth to figuring it out to speed it up from the pedals all the way up to the. F. Brad just to stop you.
So this is giving me a seventy one year i says i was saying before they were no speed up.
You can see it's just going to the whole of the state now. I reckon i can get it from you have to bet.
Then they haven't read you by showing you what sort of morsels would come out of you.
Sort of things would you use it for this is what i've got them here at the moment is a. Juice a blended base.
So i can just produce or a blender something on top of it but underneath here it's a very clear mandate.
So i can put a check into that.
Take this off
and put anything i like onto it because it's with a very can manage check you can get any that say anything.
Driven by an electric motor that say hopefully with a mode of bent out so you can have a good excuse to pull up the
pieces. And you just keep it down or you strip the major down until just after the drive.
And you just insert the drive shaft into the check.
Save an instantly turn but used to be an electrical apparatus into a mechanical driven apparatus.
What about the rest of the house. Well.
A lot of people seem to get the idea when they hear about me that i run everything with better pair but i don't.
I use paper power. Mostly for. Direct mechanical conversion like that at least in machines i just showed you.
All my other pair is just better based electricity. Going to better bank gets jash by solar panels. System.
And a couple of small bicycle when to. How long ago since you paid an electricity bill. G. Twenty years.
I think i would have saved many many thousands of dollars and. Do so.
Do you develop sort of prototypes that eventually end up in products that are right that.
I haven't done that for a while i have developed a few predator quite some time ago but most of the research
and development with iran but that is now done by other people i tend to be full time involved with. That with.
Writing stuff and. And communicating with clients and stuff. Yeah. I'm paid a pedals.
I was instrumental in the whole of things in the and of course lately.
With the setting up with it with the whole concept behind the rain but then a company that was my idea.
But before then. I set up. And film society in in. Stablish than in the news.
Which you probably know about the local rag and. I was very instrumental in setting up. The stad office being rainbow.
Which is now become the nimbin neighborhood sand. Plus a whole lot of other things i guess. Between in between and.
Yeah. I was straddling. For a number of years i came back to a stray a year in seventy one seventy two.
And then i heard on the grapevine that there was a festival in the offing in the mini area and.
I had lost as overseas i'd heard lots of bad. The.
Woodstock festival and some big festivals in europe and stuff and i thought this is be graded.
Wouldn't mind going to that. Best of all. I get my ears to the ground and.
Found out exactly when and where it was and i think it was may seventy three was and when the festival was held
and i came up here and had a really great time and decided that this would be actually be the place to live you know.
I had traveled up and then use the coast of australia i actually traveled throughout most of the strain.
And with that with the idea of working out where i'd really like to live and.
Once i'd been at the festival here decided this be the place for me so. I went away.
To sydney for a few years to try and just a lot of money to buy some land and set myself up. Didn't get very fat.
Just say more stories and more you earn the fast you spend.
I decided to come back anyway after a couple of years and said lynn neary
and soon as i got here i made getting myself involved in community projects.
When i was in sydney i was involved with down to a drop in center in paddington.
And i did all sorts of things there including showing films and stuff to people
and bought some projector equipment stuff with me and then been in the decided to stay with the set up a film.
And film. And i did that for quite some time. Showing films. Every week. For a couple of years.
And i found that there was very poor communications in this area. And there's people.
You know there's lots of music music goes into syria.
Lots of people doing all sorts of entertainment but mostly musicians.
And i always found that there was a to nothing happening at all where everybody was doing their thing all of the.
Same time. You know.
And it was always a great conflict everybody wanted to go do everything at once
and of course some people ended up missing out and you know.
And i thought this is crazy we've got to do something about this. So i set up the news.
Dextrostat off being the name in news letter. And they don't know.
So i was to drop off a letter and just make it in the news but the it was just starting off as a just a few new sheets.
Giving information to people that what's happening in the local area. And again that was something i did.
Once a week every week so as soon as i got here i made myself pretty busy you know doing all these things.
But that worked really well had a great following with a name in news and.
People were a lot better informed about who was doing what and when and where.
And there was found there's a lot less conflict as a result. And everybody really liked it.
And then i went one step further and i just thought i'd set up an office in town
and just make the information office and the call that the rainbow.
And that i was involved in for a number of years as well. All of this was pretty well unpaid. And then.
The rainbow info. Government founding and.
Some of the government founding attracted was neighborhood center founding
and so we ended up changing the name into the name and information and neighborhood center.
Later on i think the new information you've got dropped off and now it's become the new neighborhoods and.
This is a number of projects that. I guess number of things in that wouldn't have been there with there.
If it hadn't been for me standing those things off. That many years ago.
When i voiced had the desire to be self-sufficient. Whatever that may mean.
I mean as as you get older and wiser you realize that there is only so much that you can do.
And it's very you had i mean it's impossible even to be self-sufficient.
And have any kind of modern technology around you. You know. I guess even.
In all sorts of other respects we do need social interaction with people so i guess. The concept of self-sufficient it.
Depending on what extent you want to take it to if you want to take it to the extreme i guess it's just a pie in the
sky i don't think anybody can really achieve that.
But on the other hand we can be self-sufficient to some extent you know we can only veggies
and you know we can do is what i'm doing at home and what we're doing here is become pretty.
Self-sufficient with their requirements. You can catch your own rainwater of course.
So there's all sorts of things that you can do for yourself that don't require a lot of effort or. Sacrifice.
Twelve years living twelve years ago. I had the idea of of setting up a company. Just an idea.
There's a friend of mine doing. Maggot research in nimbin. He was founded to do that and the.
Invited me to join his group to work on. Concepts of setting up. Different things to make people less dependent on.
Security and hopefully. Employed in some degree or other. And. I then stad working on this idea i had.
And i put that into into this guy submission and. At that time i came up with. The name of the rainbow company.
A lot of the concept behind it. And even the logo for the i does even design the logo for that stage.
Now i think you'll find that there's some record somewhere of those submissions.
But since then i spend a lot of time just talking to people about this and going around.
Actually doing some work in that area i mean i've always been interested in renewable energy.
Is one of these areas that shows a lot of interest in the face of what i found was that
when people spoke about renewable energy systems very often. Conveniently or otherwise.
The idea of human pair was left out of the picture. And i thought this. Should really sort of.
Make a point with that and try to demonstrate that human.
They are is actually something the door to be considered is very worthwhile. Considering.
Particularly when you look at the amount of time. And many an effort that people put into. Into fitness. You know.
People buy expensive fitness equipment. To put into their own.
They complain about the cost of their electricity bills and whatever they are they're spending a fortune on all this.
Labor saving equipment they've got around the house. And then they have in order to try and create.
Time in order to spend time with these fitness programs right.
And i thought this whole concept is really crazy it's all introverted the something.
But we need to do what you know make it make a lot more sense is to have the equipment that.
Does your work and keeps your feet at the same time.
So instead of buying things three times out of you just just just spend all your time in the one hit.
Both being fit and doing your chores.
And not having to complain about all these electricity bills because you're creating your own energy to do so.
Well i guess if. If you're going to going to spend a lot of time on fitness projects.
You might as well just do a worthwhile tour in the process. It's just seem to be. Perfectly sensible you know.
If other people see the kind of logic that i've got just same so logical if you're going to spend time doing it. Doing.
You know. Some fitness project in this world. Use the energy that you. That you're generating in this.
In this fit in this thing that you're doing. To do it you're at the same time. Well.
My concept of the range at our company was. To have a company first of all that employed people obviously.
That's a company where. The employer. The employees. Were the decision makers.
I like the idea of having a company that was. I guess a bit of a cooperative in some sense. So that.
I didn't like the idea of having a pyramid structure where you've got one central manager managing director all with
ever passing. Decisions all the way down the line and all the workers are all sort of.
Slaving away and complaining about the whole structure
and not being able to do anything about it i wanted to create a structure that was quite different.
Where all the decisions were coming from from the grassroots up rather than from the from structure from the top down
or so when the company.
You know the fans of the company to come from those workers as well as the company got set up now. As it developed.
We had a meeting. I was you know. As i was saying i'll go back through the stupid. Little bit more now.
First of all i had this concept in later on there was a couple of people living nearby who said
but won't you just go and do something of the other night so we put in thirty dollars a piece
and bought some gear instead of selling at local markets under the banner of the rain that our company.
Company was and wasn't an official company as yet. That sort of spread the word.
A lot better than just talking about this. And then a few years later actually it was february of. Eighty seven.
That somebody else. Heard a bell and said look let's let's actually get.
Rolling properly now and call it a public meeting. So meeting was called in favor of eighty seven.
Demand a source factory in the nimba neighborhood center as it was then.
To see if we could get all the expertise all together in new in the one place to formalize the company properly.
So we had the meeting and we found the.
Required skills were all there at the meeting and everybody's really came to go on with it.
So we actually decided to set up a company. And in july eighty seven.
We had a company registered in the northeast of eighty seven we set up shop in newman.
And since then we've never looked back. Just just going from. Good to better to. You know.
Well to start with we were selling. Mostly just reselling.
You know just we still resell all of that we've been through through this time i guess the products have been.
Become a lot better researched. To start with. We had some of their own products not many.
But just things like control boards. We did make their own regulators familiar face.
We made their own rechargeable torches right from the beginning.
And then we were right at that meeting of february seventh i told you bet we decided then that one of the products that
we really get to get up and running. Was the hydro the. My god you know they exist and.
So we put a lot of effort into that. To actually be able to come up with a good product and to start selling it.
But it still took us almost a year before we actually got there first. First ones. On to this floor and really.
Well i guess. I've always been into making things public. You know. As with a company we don't like and.
We don't really endorse the idea of copyright and of painting and that's the stuff.
We tend not to paid and anything here.
We just like things to be public knowledge and to be aired in the public arena so to speak and.
So i said i've often been writing material. With a view of publishing a just a make or this information.
Public knowledge and.
We wanted to be able to produce a catalog for the for the rain but our company just to show people what the product.
We didn't. Wanted to just be a catalog.
We wanted it to be a lot more than we wanted it to be a handbook you know so that people could read it
and could learn from it themselves of how to do all this stuff for themselves without having to employ some experience
you know to to do all this stuff for you know the thing with low voltage systems is that you. Don't need to have.
Have a qualified person to install it for you. Theoretically anybody can install their own.
Low vol that system because there's really no danger or great danger involved.
The biggest danger that you possibly may have is the possibility of setting your house and fire but.
If you do it properly. And you put fuses in your system and stuff then it's not going to happen anyway.
So we thought this is a great opportunity to keep the power with the people.
Just reminded me of john lennon song a bit.
But you know the idea of have you know of making the skills available to everybody. So i stand. To write the book.
With a view of a standing offer.
With a view of it being the rain that their company catalog that i thought would be a lot more than that.
So i wrote it in a way that you don't need any. Fantastic skills to understand it. You know.
Written in layman's language. So that anybody with with just the basics of primary school education.
Could understand a book
and with any kind of skills of doing anything for themselves at all they should be able to also put up their own power
system. So that book. Was finally ready. I guess and. Bet.
Much the same terms are just system as was the shop floor and immediately was a great success.
That was our first edition many sixth edition. With in the meantime we've sold them.
And it was selling faster and faster stone goes on so it's turned out to be. A very popular book. Company. It was.
You'd expect of course.
When we first opened up shop in in august of eighty seven we we had to make enough money just to support one person.
But the word soon spread. That we were there and. Just joins in with the figures but.
In the first year i think we made of. Hundred thousand or something. I think.
But since then we've been growing at a rate of forty five to fifty percent per annum.
Right up until last year we've slowed down a bit.
In the last year but it looks now actually that was down to take off again.
So it was a growth rate of forty to forty five percent. Brendan for four years.
And then slowed down and that looks like we're probably going to go back up and that's the same. Growth rate.
Which makes it very difficult that kind of growth rate because it's like trying to run.
When you've had to learn to crawl. You know. And that's the way the company's been going all along.
You know now we're employing twenty people.
We've got a turnover of excess of a million dollars i think that we'll probably hit at least one half million this year.
And we still growing. We've set up another company called re shape. Which is so.
Reshape is their overseas magazine company.
And we say that we predict that is going to really take off in the next couple of years. And it reshape is going to.
Far exceed. Say. I was within the strain. At present where we're selling this trail you know wide.
But take off i think that the salesman this trail is only going to be a drop in the bucket is compared to say i was
overseas so i can see it we're going to go through and number of really huge growth spurts yet.
One of the problems with promoting renewable energy. In a stray idea.
Is that the people that need to know about most of the people there in remote areas and.
The greatest difficulty getting and advertising to remote areas.
Is very easy to get to a city suburban environment but. As it stands at the moment.
That's not where i say i was like i say i was you know i think. For instance. If you look at homestead.
Cattle stations etc. A lot of them are running on very big generators and.
In this day and age and saying that they should rely for all that they are a few are being exploited
or transported all over the country for them. And the same of course. Same idea holds true for.
Countries overseas you know. When we have any kind of. Overseas aid programs in.
Invariably with what they give to these people overseas is these with generators and to me that's totally insane.
You know. These people can't afford to buy the diesel for him. And usually what happens is makes people feel good that.
Send it to them you know and maybe also wonderful.
Tax dodging all sorts of stuff that is no use to these people at all you know first of all they don't have the
mechanical skill to maintain the equipment. And secondly that. You know in small pacific islands or remote areas.
Southeast asia we're talking about.
It's just too expensive for for them to get the days where they just can't afford it. So we need to.
You know it's a it makes a lot more sense to in these areas to have over the energy systems.
You know once the system is up and running it maintains itself. You know you put a solar panel up in the sand.
And you know it. It will have the capability of charging a better way for the next thirty years and.
You know without doing anything to it you don't know moving parts
and you don't have to maintain your thing there's nothing to fix in it.
You just placed in the sand connected better do it in a better or just keep on being challenged by it.
So in remote areas of australia and.
Anywhere else in the world i guess it just makes a much more sense to have energy systems that.